[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
so you weren't invented this morning
David yeah I've been a [ __ ] hurt wait
what happened well I just haven't gone
to a dentist in a gajillion years I've
never had a cavity before so I actually
have two cavities for the first time in
my life dude I've had nothing but
cavities my whole life
I mean that's most people though
apparently so I just I wait if you
haven't been how do you know you didn't
have a cavity for a good decade I know
you don't like your [ __ ] nose always
always I was telling David earlier this
morning I'll just fill with my tongue on
top of the teeth and I'll feel like
those people like if you do have a case
you'll know you know what I mean cuz I
hear your nerves yeah catch it early on
it does it comes and go sometimes yes so
I have some I have an early cavity
setting in on two teeth and she asked me
like she goes Oh have you ever gotten
make counties before I was like never so
you didn't we got failure seals that's
pretty amazing she goes like most people
by the time you're like 29 30 years old
you usually have like six or seven
cavities and I've never had it before in
my life they probably got hella good
hygiene no cavities and let me tell you
I know exactly why because I was in
Fairfax County Virginia
they put fluoride in the water oh that's
amazing for your teeth and I didn't get
no cavities therefore I hear what my
dick hanket heart that's one that is one
problem but my teeth are very clean very
clean you know I think what happened
with me - like I told it - like I only
really started drinking a lot of soda
when I moved to LA and I met this guy
named Bart Quan yup who and that's when
I started yeah cavities Tim and I
started drinking soda
ever since that and then now I'd lo
bubble to my soda guy cuz you're the
soda guy you know you indulge what's
your soda I like all of them there's a
specific way of preparing all of them so
if you're talking about coke you got to
get McDonald's coke it's different sure
what do they do what is it what about
McDonald's man and the straw soda and
the straw they have a special coke
formula yeah
not like the other Cano they have like
an exact process or sometimes I like
Mexican Coke this coke always has to
come with ice if it's no I generally
don't like story without ice see but I
didn't I do know ice cuz I like the deal
you are so [ __ ] Asian it's a bill the
[ __ ] cup with soda when I'm at the
movie theater I'm like no ice I'm like
look at me in the eye
no I don't [ __ ] me what if you split it
would be like one cup full of ice one
cup full that's what I would do cuz
that's just free we're gonna pour it in
there listen what do you mean what do
you mean one cup full of ice that's
brilliant I never thought they'd give
you an extra cup you can ask for extra
cup an empty plastic cup is the currency
no coin to them right for yourself
they're not there ah but they will give
you a little water cup you can do that
do it at our quite if you try to smuggle
in any outside candy they'll literally
throw you in jail they exactly
[ __ ] got a Doberman so it just seemed
like dark light because I like aren't
light but because because they keep the
ghetto people because because [ __ ] I
seize them is that why I like it cuz
I've always really liked it yeah it's
cuz like and they announce it but the
problem is I happen to be one of those
game people you know what makes you
ghetto loud obnoxious leave [ __ ] around
yeah I mean Casey like he likes to laugh
like really loud whenever it's something
like subtly funny and I'm always like
swear it Arclight like that's why we're
here yeah yeah yeah we're snobby we're
trying to be snobby you guys have the
good you guys have to go to AFC dude you
can see that's where you see the rowdy
movies for sure
everyone in the audience like talks to
the screen during the movie yeah I've
never been to a theater where people are
doing that oh really well you need to go
that way where people just get [ __ ]
rowdy recently [ __ ] what movies have
you seen go to the Regal Cinema like an
auction mute that what everyone's
looking rowdy on that one
Oh recently uh Josh Josh went to go see
not not JK ace so ace went to go watch
black panther at a AMC you know what the
reclining chairs and everything he
thought it was dope until like these two
dudes in the back were just like making
fun of the African accent in the back
and like you know Josh is from like
Atlantis wasn't funny he said it wasn't
accurate at all and so like but you know
you talked him through the film he start
trying to watch the film and like he
judge is like the nicest dude ever yeah
but Josh got up and he was like gonna
[ __ ] those dudes up and then literally
like they got up and they ran out but it
was like one of those moment where Josh
is not a small guy either he's actually
pretty you know yeah but there's cuz
he's so [ __ ] goofy you don't really
expect it out of the guy but then you
kind of realize he's actually like six
feet tall he's kind of like yeah but um
sees you don't have that because by the
time you do that there's a flashlight in
your [ __ ] eye and to kick you out
yeah I grew up talking to movies all the
time with my friends yeah you still do
that no you know there's that stereotype
about like black people talk at the
movie theater well most of my friends
were black in elementary to high school
and we all just talked to the movie is
that why there's no black people dark
like is that what's happening oh I see
black people in my are racist piece of
[ __ ] well maybe there's a difference
between it's different because maybe
just all ghetto like I think is a ghetto
/ Asian whatever Mexican everyone just
talks to the move like they they
interact it's an interactive experience
my roommate ray he only watches films
early in the morning or super late at
night cuz he doesn't want anybody in the
theater with us
oh he's one
weird of people's alone he goes there to
jack off movie along right yeah I got a
buddy who goes the movie alone and I'm
like like this is something that
somebody does before they kill
themselves to me actual movie watching
experience you want to be in a packed
house that's why you want to wait in
line because you there's like this
cathartic effect that you feel across
it's like stand up going live like
watching a stamp special at home is so
different than watching it live or not
not necessarily an empty theater but you
go alone
I got a comedy - comical be right that's
the real kill yourself I always told
people my favorite idea for like if
you're gonna kill if you already know
you're gonna kill yourself there's only
one way to do it right you go to
somebody's improv show or their stand-up
show right and no matter what they're
doing on stage like you wait till like
the midpoint of their act and you blow
your [ __ ] head off right no so then
no matter what because I know these
people
like they always like like my buddy used
to come home like from I used to more my
room an improviser and and when he came
home if you had a bad show it was like
how was it man it's like oh well it was
it was good but like like you know we
had this problem so so if you blow your
[ __ ] head off during their show they
have to go home that night and it's like
how was the show it's like oh it was
pretty good it's like I mean you know
one guy did kill himself during the show
like like there's no better way to go
out if you're already gonna do it I
don't think I would ever do stand-up
comedy ever he just stood up boom just
like well my career's done I would take
it personally like ma'am I said suck
that bad well then what do you have to
do is you have to set it up that you
were really happy everything was awesome
and your life was going really really
well until you went to that show so that
no matter what is like your fault that
this guy cause he [ __ ] crazy little
ass that stand-up comedian was a
youtuber they would just keep going
because people tell about their content
sucks all the time they don't care
nothing so jarring is this no ultimate
test what the [ __ ] what stage in your
life did you think about this oh when I
used to when I used to do improv shows
like four or five times a week and then
hearing the excuses that my friends
would make like if it was a bad show so
then now that's a real legitimate excuse
I think so and then you give people a
pass exactly so someone should kill
themselves at a improv show just so they
could give someone a pass that is very
interesting though all I went to one
improv show ever and it was really bad
yeah that's pretty much it's it's it's
missing miss and and there's no one
forced yeah there's normally it feels
like forced humor like it's like
everyone's in on it and I'm just sitting
there like I'm not stupid I know what's
going on this is stupid
it's working really well it's working so
well that you're like wow that was one
of the best things I've ever seen
and but normally it's like I really wish
I didn't go pay for parking and do this
it's just like stand-up though like just
because you go to a stand-up comedy show
it doesn't mean you're guaranteed to
laugh there's plenty of times where I
went and laughter the whole [ __ ]
thing but there's other nights where I
went to a comedy club and I was dying
laughing so sucks cuz that's a spectator
I'm always like if I'm gonna pay for
something I'm like guaranteed laughs
that's why you have to have an open mind
when you go to these things though like
you can't have a preconceived notion and
get ready to judge people you just be
there for the experience to see what
happens that's also why they got a
two-drink minimum yep it's really it's
not just about recouping money there
it's like dreams to make it funnier but
like yeah like me and Nicky's you know
how I mean I already knew that I was
gonna marry Nicky but pretty early on we
were all at a stand-up show well no
we're pretty early on we were all at a
stand-up show and me and a bunch of
friends Nicky and me and her were not
laughing at the same [ __ ] and everyone
else was laughing at it and I was like
I'm [ __ ] marry the [ __ ] of this girl
you know I mean because like just an
identical she gets your humor yeah yeah
the same say something like that about
me okay now how much time have you have
that many things to say yeah sweet
things
he needs a feature length you know film
to do that yeah yeah he just doesn't
tell you in your face but he tells the
rest of us yeah yeah I remember this one
time he's like you know how you know how
I know I was gonna keep you I was like
why what happened because like she's she
wants to work out through problems and
then like I was like ready to leave but
then she's not so I was like I'm a
keeper I'm like that's dog he calls you
his happiest mistake yep you said I'm a
mistake no he made oh yeah the happiest
mistake Thutmose like how many kid that
you don't want but you turn a little I
know I always try that but that is a
happy mistake I'm getting close man
to the kid talk oh it's like the walls
are closing in how do you know huh you
could feel it from Nicky or oh you are
you both are talking about it yeah I
mean all that [ __ ] she says you know all
about that we had to we had to a couple
days ago well that's why she's like
getting off bit because she's like
getting a healthy like womb ready and I
don't know maybe someone she just said
that your dick is so big that you can
literally a print it the ink from when
you [ __ ] her you just go right in and
just go right to the ridiculous that's
what she said your dick would just go
literally right there just go straight
to the [ __ ] egg and it just goes she
said yeah hey if you could pick one
where girl yeah I'll tell you right now
I want a boy and if I get a girl I'll be
sad about it he'll listen don't listen
to him he's lying he's sad about it I
used to think that but I actually wanted
a girl now because here's the thing the
firstborn daughter right she's gonna
[ __ ] take care of you she's gonna
stick around if you do a good job
raising her yeah and if you have a son
or another daughter after that she's
gonna take care of that I'm gonna debunk
that real quick right now I'm
the second girl and the third kid the
third kid the oldest one ain't doing
[ __ ] for my pants the oldest daughter
yes well when you were growing up though
did she help out yes that's the that's
the good it's well they make better
slaves than boys that's what I'm saying
way better than females are way better
asleep I agree good take care of my
brothers yeah that's very true yeah
[ __ ] apart maybe five years my
sister's the oldest did she help take
care of you hun percent yep yeah see
that's the only reason why [ __ ] man
just give her the walk go Paperclip yeah
no to be honest I do want to go first
yeah but if I if I get a boy too it'll
be cool I'll be said is it's whatever if
I get a boyfriend okay
why yeah I guess cuz my and my older
sister was was dope growing up and it
was I liked it like I was I don't know
like I didn't have like all this like
guy guy [ __ ] like hang on [ __ ] like I
was always like pretty cool to chicks
cuz I knew like I've learned from my
sister and that's what they say they
guys that have older sisters are more
emotionally intelligent oh that's my
brother yeah yeah then then the flip
side then a guy with a younger sister
yeah my old man was never ran so I was
like just my mom my sister like all the
time you know you think I was real
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I am your jab at your
cross yeah I'm ready to go dude I'm a
[ __ ] powder keg but you careful like
dealt war with words this beware of dog
you know that's my [ __ ]
I think about it like what we want like
well we would like to have max like in
terms of kids I don't know I really
wouldn't mind I wouldn't mind if it
would be a boy first are you gonna do it
you guys gonna do it for sure yeah I
forgot about Isaac like that huh no I'm
talking about
because I'd look like an only child like
that's already that's already a thing
like he grew up on his own he's by the
time these kids come along he's gonna be
a teenager probably so how about we
don't assume the gender how about
oh my god when I post it about when I
posted the sonogram of tyka I was like
oh what do you guys guess it's gonna be
like the gender it's gonna be a boy or
girl and people are like don't assume so
boring are we gonna say don't assume the
species I'm a worm I'm coming out the
[ __ ] shell I'm a while you know
what's so weird because I used to say
you know like oh it's gonna have a
snowball effect doesn't know it's not
like what's going on getting out of hand
if somebody was telling my [ __ ]
Instagram I swear to God I can't do
anything what are you gonna get sued
yeah I'll be your ass and get sued to
hell how about that I'll be penniless
guys how about that from this I have no
money right now from this moment on I'm
a marsupial there you go what is it more
soup you I never know I'm always a great
a mammal hairless or male military
watches it's like a possum it's like a
special type of mammal like platypus
kangaroo koala mm-hmm koalas have
pouches too you throw up they're born a
different way I mean they all have like
a little pouch oh [ __ ] I got a pouch to
us Todd post has eggs they lay eggs that
was the weirdest thing
how the puss is like one of those things
that God definitely got drunk legit got
[ __ ] wasted and then he was like well
it's already there having the people on
the earth on my car got drunk I'm so
happy you said that I've always felt
that yeah it's true it's true
mmm yeah at Walmart I think that all the
time
yeah I go to Walmart you go to Walmart a
lot dude that night in the middle that'd
be sad weren't even warmer he's one of
those people but he doesn't realize he's
none of that he goes enough to be one of
them Wow
what do you do or man I need to buy
stuff sometimes you need to get a vacuum
cleaner and some other [ __ ] apples
they just got great deal what about
Amazon yeah she comes to know I like
look it comes to day sometimes
not better than Walmart it's just some
there's a atmosphere in there that was
very sad
you know I did find out though I just
think the Amazon had like the best deals
in prices it doesn't like cuz I would
like price check like on Walmart or
something and there are [ __ ] Chinese
dude I know but I have rice checking
Amazon what the [ __ ] yeah well you got
two percent of Alibaba curate this way
to personality in store qualities in
store you could get a cheaper like I was
gonna get what's it called [ __ ]
Listerine like the [ __ ] [ __ ] how much
does this rain do you really need it was
like a gallon bottle it was like you
don't use mouthwash every day no that's
mask you hear me complain about it well
maybe you should buy me a bottle oh we
do yes like that dude for me Costco one
and then around the [ __ ] cup of the
Ring it just yet there's a real [ __ ]
Listerine calcium and it just sits for a
year or two oh my god if you use it
after it's gone back cuz one time I use
a Listerine that we have here at the
office and it already expired and it was
the blue kind and then I rinse my mouth
and my teeth turn blue you always get
stuck with the expired [ __ ] man I gotta
follow your hives because you don't have
cavities right yeah [ __ ] whatever you're
doing can you write your [ __ ] mouth
programs and programs it's like my god
dude you with your [ __ ] list I need
to know what to do so number one happy
Laroy it's just your [ __ ] dentist
annual I don't have cavities right now I
know Bo I'm looking up I gave you an
appointment and we switched it like
three times already I stopped using the
left side of my mouth for like a whole
year ready cuz it's hurting what I love
how do you have to repeat what she just
said back to you but with an intensity I
know I have to have these right now and
Jill's like I [ __ ] know I will tell
you this if you don't get your cavities
fixed like if it already hurts that much
you're like probably this close to
getting a root canal and if you have
multiple ones you're gonna get [ __ ] you
my appointment for me
[Music]
right no one's booking my appointments
off I'm not going I just said I booked
it and switched it like three times cuz
you could make it so when he says or the
fourth time someone it's a booked it and
drive me back while I take a nap you
need an assistant
I know [ __ ] so it's the way he solves
his problems right so he gets a cavity
he goes it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] then he gets a
chocolate bar starts chewing on I wish
that the scientific community would
release fake articles to force men to do
[ __ ] that we don't want to do that's one
thing that you wouldn't think like like
for example with with Bart right it's
like guys who don't brush your teeth
every day have dick problems it's like
yeah but that shit's a [ __ ] fable cuz
I didn't brush my teeth for weeks I had
the worst hygiene and I only have five
cavities ish until I was failing no runs
under five categories if you'd say it's
like down the road you're gonna have
dick problems because of this [ __ ]
you'll brush your teeth yeah if someone
lied to me and said my dicks gonna
[ __ ] decrease yeah they got to use
that lab coat for good yeah you don't
say the more you brush your teeth the
bigger your dick becomes it's just all
in the basic [ __ ] so like staying away
from soda which I did for most of my
life and down at this man yeah you
[ __ ] me and then I got I finally got
two very minor cavities that I have to
fix how many time did they brush your
teeth twice and then you what do you do
use Listerine you should floss like
flossing is [ __ ] important it doesn't
so many times like flossing is like
flossing so [ __ ] boring though I
forgot to do it you know I needed to be
fun I need to be more fun flossing is
[ __ ] annoying try the water line
what's the water floss the water piks to
like there's not the same huh it's not
that it's not a better at much the same
pressurized water that like goes through
your teeth
really and actually fluxes for you with
water the water floss basically is
supposed to help you with like worth it
it cleans your gums too problem is a lot
of people don't know how to use it well
and on top of that nothing actually
beats actual flossing yeah cuz do you
need that to get in between the guns and
scrape it off so like it's it's one of
those things that people like
like dentist they say it's cool but
doesn't mean that you can't not floss
even when you're washing their dishes
you ever use the jet yeah and it's
strong as [ __ ] right and because I'm so
lazy I wanna watch this is just some
blasting the dishes I'm just waiting and
then that [ __ ] stain still there I'm
like god damn it
I let the snake go back in and you
barely touch it and nothing falls off
yeah so I realized that this touch is
actually way stronger than the one yeah
so its supplemental so it's not like
you're gonna get that and you don't
floss so it's just gonna do that and
floss so [ __ ] that [ __ ] just flops thank
you so lazy if if I had a hose outside I
would just take my dishes out there for
dishes and you're not going to smell so
good for you thank you
maybe you wanna if you don't want to
brush your teeth just chew on bones
because that's dogs toothbrushes well I
did that and I chipped one of my molars
just buy some pork ribs you just like
eat an apple and then if you don't have
like a toothbrush around or whatever you
cleaned it or you could just brush your
[ __ ] sugar in the Apple slowly can
get the skin you know you know [ __ ]
tooth brushing is so important even in
the military we do like seven days of
like training evolutions out in the
mountains and you don't have enough
sleep you're [ __ ] getting hazed the
whole time there's still always like
three minutes that they allow you to go
brush your teeth in the morning and at
night that's how important it is so even
in [ __ ] warfare it's [ __ ] I love
how you know all this [ __ ] yet you still
can't make your ass to an appointment
what point was way different because the
point I'm stupid no one's booking my
appointment for me yeah and the cool
thing about is to like even for Mila I
didn't go to a dentist for a long time
like I upkeep my teeth really well but
even then it's not enough so it's like I
mean including your teeth it's like once
a year you know what I mean it's not
really that much I got good teeth just
stinking breath dude I [ __ ] up my toes
like I always get ingrown toenails
always like cuz I always cut them wait I
cut them too short
yeah I love cuz I love cutting him short
man cuz it prolongs cutting them that's
right
then I have to do it again
so so last night I really [ __ ] up like
big stunts you petted - no I had an
ingrown I had an ingrown and in there
and I just you know I'd do this thing
where I got to be a tough guy in cell
operate so I I pulled it out right but I
took like half of the nail with me wrap
my toe up like to get in bed because it
was like bleeding so crazy then Nicky
think you're a badass no she's dead
asleep and she thinks I'm a [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] with him when I'm doing this
[ __ ] she's like just go to the tow guy
and I'm like I don't wanna [ __ ] yeah
wait a hundred fifty but yeah to go get
to go I have them like glance it out or
whatever so I like to do it myself
they'll rip out the root that's what
they do because my grandpa would be like
you know in the core we we used to be up
in the we're in the [ __ ] mud and we'd
have to do it ourselves with a [ __ ]
Rock and I'm like all right I can do
this with utensils you don't I mean I
used to brush my teeth with the rock
like old people when they do that right
they go well back in my day I used to
[ __ ] myself with the elephant horn it's
a well listen dude doesn't mean it was
right it just means you did it back in
the day pick up the [ __ ] what does that
be
[Music]